I have a question for you yeah are you
still friends with Jeff
uh yeah or friendly yeah I saw him at a
wedding a couple weeks ago and we
chatted and how do you feel about that
what is your take on that oh gosh it's
gonna get me in trouble
um not if you're being listen I'm
totally honest I I listen I I I love
David you know like David's my friend
I'm close with David right I support
David you know I'm support David through
anything at the same time you know I
wish Jeff the best and I hope that you
know it all works out but you know David
I I you know I'm I'm there for him
I get it you were there for them they're
two guys who were really good friends
yeah and Jeff was incredible in the
videos and and and not even just in the
videos but as a person Jeff uh Jeff
helped me lose like 20 pounds once he
would like come over to my house and
work me out and like especially when I
had a breakup you know he came and he
was like Jason we're gonna [ __ ] you
know get you back into shape and he's
like that's Staten Island kind of thing
about him you were you were standing
there when he hit the the crane right no
I went to the I was a I I went into town
to go to the bathroom I missed it I was
not there for that it's something that I
yeah I think about a lot it sucks I wish
I wished I was there so how did you find
out like what so what happened you come
back from the bathroom come out of a
Walgreens and Susie antonian uh calls me
and says there's been an accident meet
us at Utah Valley Hospital
and it was awful and it's just like it's
very it's very painful for for everybody
you know I would imagine for Jeff and
it's painful for all of us too is there
no way out of it besides I know there's
a legal battle right now so there's only
so much is it no way it just seems and
I'm just asking from the outside yeah
yeah yeah it just seems that Jeff's
biggest problem was the fact that
um he wanted more interaction from David
is David just too
isn't it the fact that he didn't visit
him enough in the hospital he didn't
even ask him how he was doing both I
watched both I did a little research
okay but and then David explained that
it was hard for him and he didn't know
how to act in that situation right like
wasn't Jeff saying that his biggest
problem is that he didn't feel like
there was enough remorse coming from
David and David felt like he didn't know
what to do in that situation
um
uh yeah I think that he Jeff probably
wanted that more from David and then I
also think that
she maybe David didn't maybe did reach
out but didn't or didn't know to reach
out because Jeff's like such a tough guy
and
um I really don't know I get kind of
both sides in the sense that it's
literally horrible they did this to me
on BFFs they did the same thing and it's
like I understand like you want to know
about it and I don't really
I don't know the inner workings I don't
know if David called them or I or like
Jeff I heard something that Sarah I
didn't pay the medical bills but I think
what really happened was they didn't
know about the medical bills there's so
much like back and forth about it and
but isn't it isn't the major thing just
between them both communication like I
feel like we have we being just a
general public and maybe you also have
um tidbits from both sides but both
sides aren't together like everything
that I hear them saying right why aren't
they saying it to each other yeah from
both sides you know I don't know they
just can't get on the same page or I
really don't know I I don't know what
what exactly are you talking about like
you're saying you're wondering about the
lawsuit like I know now it's a lawsuit
I'm not asking you about it yeah I'm
asking you about listen two friends are
working together nobody was doing you
know whether it's irresponsible or
responsible isn't even the issue they're
both working together they're doing
something an accident happens it's
called an accident because it's an
accident it's an accident and now
because of these act because of this
accident they are no longer friends
right Beyond let's not talk about the
lawsuit they're no longer friends so how
do you patch that up I saw you do the
podcast where he tried to reach out to
um Jeff as far as his View and then I
hear you hear Jeff talk about it yeah
but you don't hear them or even see them
at this point no I don't think tickets
for Parable I mean really I don't I
don't know if I don't you'd have to ask
them I wasn't asking about you about
them or their takes or anything I was
asking about you like your relationship
now because I know you are closer with
David yeah and that's your guy I'm
asking about your relationship now with
Jeff if you have one how that's been for
you if it's hard because I know that you
were very close at one point to everyone
that you were yeah it's super hard I
mean I see Jeff I saw him a wedding who
talked and then I saw him at Runyon the
other day because we do Todd and I do
running in the morning and Jeff does
running a lot I saw him there he's super
nice he's super upbeat he looks great
he's moving on with his life right and
uh and he was super kind to me and he's
super kind is it uncomfortable for you
no not uncomfortable at all I mean you
know these are these are grown men and
they they have that issue and they have
to figure it out you know it's not
uncomfortable for me when I if I see
Jeff or if I see David or if I see
Trisha so there's not a sense of divide
in the friend group it's interesting to
hear because
from our point of view outside yeah the
Trisha thing was explosive yeah yeah and
and even Beyond you you know the this
issues that she's had Beyond you after
you have always been incredibly
explosive so just it's just I try to I
try to do I try to have empathy for
everybody I think it's really important
you know I especially because they're
younger uh Jeff is a lot younger than me
David's a lot younger than me and I just
having more years than them I understand
that you know why people do things where
they come from I understand Jeff's side
I understand David's side and I also
just try to approach everybody with
empathy you know Trisha had a horrible
horrible upbringing I mean awful and I
don't want to go into it but so when
she's coming after me
I I try to look at it like oh there's a
there's a reason for that you know or if
if you look at anybody you know when you
go after when people go after like Shia
LaBeouf for example right he's crazy
Shia LaBeouf's crazy he's like well no
he was a kid actor you know he had a
tough dad and so yeah it's probably
gonna make you a little nuts you know so
that's how that's how I I try to look at
it that's understanding it yeah but then
you don't feel like any proactivity as
far as maybe trying to quell it or
getting people back together I have
tried you seem like The Peacemaker I Am
The Peacemaker I have we I have tried to
put them together in a room and
um and David tried you know we invited
Jeff on the podcast that we did which
you know honestly we didn't feel good
about after we did it that was a mistake
I thought you know even though we said
our side of it or David's at his side
because but it's because you know you
don't want to do it publicly even this
what we're doing right now and I
understand you want to know and it's
it's great content but even doing this
right now is like ah [ __ ] it's like is
this gonna make David feel like [ __ ] so
it's gonna make Jeff feel like [ __ ] and
it's well I hope it doesn't I'm saying
that right away I have no uh and I'm
concerned you know I am I'm I'm always
concerned for their well-being
especially as the oldest uh the oldest
guy in the group my point was not them
like I know that they can speak for
themselves my entire body is cramping up
talking about sorry we can move on no no
no stay on you and your feelings about
it and how it affected you and your life
personally
it sucks it sucks I mean we all love
Jeff yeah I mean Jeff was like the best
[Music]